le 7 8 sur TVfil bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez les 18h en direct une heure
pour faire le point sur l'information
locale aujourd'hui mardi 5 mars je
reçois déjà sur ce plateau Nick Thomas
c'est bonsoir La dartyan du monde face à
vous Maya Saad bonsoir à vous elle
libanaise vous êtes en charge de l'appui
au producteurs de faire trade les
bananes un acteur de l'évolution
agricole dans ce pays on en parlera tout
à l'heure bonsoir à toutes les deux on
parlera plus principalement du rôle des
femmes dans la dynamique de
transformation sociale c'est un petit
peu l'objectif de ce que vous organisez
il y a un rendez-vous qui est prévu
d'ailleurs ce soir du côté de Trappes
pour l'instant voici les titres du jour
quelques-uns des sujets à suivre
également ce soir elle est syndicat CGT
FO mobilisés contre la corne nationale
interprofessionnelle à la CGT a appelé à
manifester sur plusieurs points du
département dont Vélizy devant
l'entreprise Alcatel qui est d'ailleurs
menacé une résidence étudiante sera
construite à Maurepas pour la rentrée
2014 la première pierre vient d'être
posée posée 183 studios seront réalisés
une résidence dont la particularité est
d'être modulable le droit de vote des
étrangers pour les élections locales le
projet n'est pas nouveau il avait été
souhaité par François Mitterrand repris
par François Hollande et pourrait se
concrétiser en 2014 en tout cas cela
fait débat aussi bien chez les élus au
sein de la population tour de réserve et
justement presque un an avant les
élections municipales de mars 2014 les
formations politiques s'organisent l'UDI
l'Union des démocrates et indépendants
grand rassemblement des forces du centre
à lancer son regroupement officiel dans
les Yvelines et nous verrons leur
stratégie et puis la réponse d'une autre
force centriste le modem il sera aussi
question d'environnement la chronique de
l'environnement ce soir avec Julie Rocha
Suarez bonsoir Julie et ce soir nous
allons parler botanique
nous allons découvrir comment se soigner
par les plantes et pour cela Christelle
Bonal une botaniste indépendante viendra
sur notre plateau avec un échantillon de
plantes printanières et à nous
présentera ses vertus médicinales et
aussi culinaires la chronique de
l'environnement ce sera dans une
vingtaine de minutes voilà pour le
programme de ce soir et puis à noter
également qu'une large page de cette
édition sera consacrée au Salon de
l'Automobile de Genève le département
des Yvelines est bien représenté quatre
projets de PME soutenus par le Conseil
Général s'expose aux visiteurs du monde
entier le détail tout à l'heure
le commerce équitable est aussi une
question de liberté et d'indépendance
pour ces femmes qui s'engagent notamment
au Liban ou en Palestine artisan du
monde à souhaiter les mettre en avant
les mettre à l'honneur à l'occasion de
la Journée internationale des droits des
femmes ce sera le 8 mars tout simplement
la première question que je vais vous
poser à Nick Thomas c'est pourquoi
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix de mettre
en avant ces différents initiatives au
Liban et au Palestine alors artisan du
monde et de toute façon ils le commerce
équitable en général sont très liés aux
droits des femmes puisque par exemple
partisan du monde 120 des organisations
de producteurs avec lesquels nous
travaillons sont sur les 120 avec
lesquels nous travaillons plus de la
majorité de son
majoritairement des femmes y compris
dans les équipes dirigeantes et un
certain nombre ont été créés par des
femmes ça veut dire que le but c'est de
montrer à comment s'émancipe sur le plan
économique sur le plan politique ces
femmes via le commerce équitables voilà
et c'est un facteur le commerce
équitable est un levier extrêmement
important puisque à partir du moment où
les femmes
où elles ont une valeur économique où
elle gagne leur vie et bien le regard
des gens enfin de la société sur elle
change de leur famille et de la société
sur elle change éventuellement même du
monde politique dans un deuxième temps
deuxième temps quelques chiffres un peu
appuyer justement ce que vous nous dites
à 50 % de la production agricole
mondiale issue du travail des femmes
elles assument 66% du travail effectué
dans le monde et elle gagne moins de 10%
du revenu total ce sont des chiffres
surprenants malgré tout mais qui
correspondent à la réalité parce que la
plupart du temps le travail féminin
n'est pas reconnu il se fait dans le cas
de familial il est pas du tout valorisé
ni reconnu ni rétribuer bien sûr voilà
mais en fait il est il est réel et
effectif c'est elle qui font tourner un
bon nombre de choses cette mise à
l'honneur de leur travail se fait à
l'occasion de la Journée Internationale
des Droits de la Femme le 8 mars cela va
durer un mois entier pour artisans du
monde ça va commencer dès aujourd'hui
même tout simplement puisque dès ce soir
à 18h30 dans une vingtaine de minutes si
vous me suivez en direct vous serez à
Trappes toutes les deux salles du
Conseil de la Communauté d'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin pour un échange avec le
public et vous serez donc présente Maya
Saad vous êtes en charge de l'appui au
producteurs et aux certifications pour
faire travailler les bananes c'est quoi
faire travailler les bananes alors faire
très debenon c'est une ONG locale
libanaises qui a été créé par plusieurs
personnes libanaises pour pouvoir aider
les communautés rurales et les et les
femmes rurales notamment au Liban pour
pouvoir accéder au marché et vendre
leurs produits sur le marché voilà on
peut donner un exemple concret de
réalisation qui ont été faites oui bien
sûr
l'exemple concret c'est c'est solidaire
monde en effet le solidarmonde il achète
de chez nous plusieurs produits dont
notamment les lentilles corail le pois
chiches le boulgour et aussi les attaque
qui est très en vogue chez artisan du
monde
deux de ces produits proviennent de
coopératives qui sont dans des régions
général du Liban des coopératives de
femmes notamment et deux autres produits
proviennent de petites entreprises
familiales aussi dans les régions
rurales du Liban voilà mais
véritablement ces réalisations ces
coopératives qui sont mises en place que
vous valorisez me permettent aux femmes
de justement s'émanciper aussi de
d'avoir ce développement économique
politique d'avoir une avancée dans la
société c'est ça
au Liban on peut dire que le Liban
présente le taux le plus élevé
d'émancipation pour les femmes au
Moyen-Orient mais quand même dans les
régions rurales du Liban les femmes
n'ont pas accès
au travail autonome pour pouvoir se
valoriser et valoriser le savoir-faire
libanais sur le marché voilà donc on est
là pour les aider à se valoriser à
perpétuer le savoir-faire traditionnel
libanais dans le monde et notamment en
Europe en France en Allemagne aussi un
de nos produits est au Japon aussi
jusqu'à présent très prochainement en
Allemagne voilà donc il y a des
véritables avancées mais au sein même de
la communauté libanaise justement c'est
une révolution presque culturelle aussi
il faut changer beaucoup de choses pour
permettre aussi aux femmes de s'affirmer
on parlait aussi de la Palestine tout à
l'heure parce que ça fait partie des
autres pays qui sont mis à l'honneur par
l'artisan du monde mais comment ces
perçu dans la société libanaise
c'est un pas très dynamique dans la
société libanaise les sentiments d'être
encouragé
de la fierté de pouvoir montrer aux gens
leur savoir-faire comment ils peuvent
être
fonctionnels comment ils peuvent être
valoriser voilà valoriser dans leur dans
leur communauté locale voilà le commerce
équitable qui permet véritablement de
développer la liberté l'indépendance
quelles sont les barrières que vous
rencontrez encore aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui manquerait pour que ça se développe
peut-être encore plus vite plus
rapidement le
le problème essentiel c'est l'accès au
marché voilà
et nous travaillons sur ce point pour
pouvoir
pour pouvoir vendre les produits
libanais sur le sur les marchés aussi
beaucoup plus de marché que nous le
venons voilà les autres marchés sont du
mal à vous laisser à arriver développer
vendre ses produits et voilà par exemple
maintenant nous essayons de vendre nos
produits et de percer le marché arabe
notamment il y a quelques peu de
difficultés mais
espérons qu'on pourra le faire très
prochainement voilà on parlait du Liban
la Palestine aussi puisque ce sera
l'objet aussi du rendez-vous de ce soir
quels sont les autres pays avec lesquels
par exemple vos collaborez sur le dans
le cadre de ces coopératives portées par
des femmes plein plein de pays de aussi
bien de d'Asie d'Afrique ou d'Amérique
latine mais disons que chaque année on
choisit de mettre une région ou une ou
deux organisations en et cette année
c'est donc les femmes de la Méditerranée
d'où le Liban et la Palestine en lien
avec d'abord parce qu'ils soient
beaucoup de choses en ce moment autour
de la Méditerranée voilà et puis en lien
avec le Forum social mondial aussi qui
se tient à Tunis donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a choisi effectivement
mars le Forum social mondial donc à
Tunis ça permettra aussi de montrer
qu'une autre pensée économique est
possible c'est en tout cas à ce
quartisan du monde
souhaite et vous commercialisez donc les
produits concrètement qui sont produits
vous les avez évoqués tout à l'heure
donc Artisans du Monde les
commercialistes dans toutes ces
boutiques il y a bon il y a une boutique
à Trappes par exemple l'association
locale et il y a 130 boutiques dans
toute la France donc où on trouve ces
produits
et puis voilà les lentilles corail enfin
les pois chiches et tout ça et pour parc
c'est de l'huile d'olive qui vient de il
y a pas tellement de production qui
peuvent sortir de Palestine donc c'est
de l'huile d'olive qui est
commercialisée par vous travaillez avec
12 de producteurs la moitié de ces
organisations sont des groupements de
femmes
qui ont souvent créées par des femmes et
sinon où les femmes sont majoritaires y
compris dans les équipes de direction
parce que la majoritaire on pourrait
dire elles font les tâches moins
intéressantes non c'est elle parfois qui
dirige et ça voilà ça marche très très
bien et ce soir il y aura ce rendez-vous
cet échange avec le public qui voudrait
en savoir plus je vous le disais ce sera
la salle du conseil de Sensei
la trappe le public peut y venir
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est de faire
connaître artisan de monde et puis de
faire connaître ce travail et ce rôle du
commerce équitable voilà acheter un
produit commercial équitable c'est bien
sûr que c'est un produit mais ça a une
vraiment une signification particulière
qu'on veut mettre en avant voilà
derrière il y a beaucoup de choses et
nous on peut l'expliquer ce qu'il y a
derrière ce qui est pas le cas toujours
vous en attendez beaucoup pour conclure
donc de ce rendez-vous de ce soir en
général quand vous présentez le travail
que vous menez les gens sont surpris
curieux ils connaissent déjà un petit
peu alors jusqu'à présent dans nos
rencontres dans les boutiques on a vu
que les gens s'intéressaient surtout aux
attards ils étaient très satisfaits et
contents de nous rencontrer peut-être
parce que nous concrétisons les produits
que
nous verrons dans les boutiques Artisans
du Monde présente dans leur boutique
voilà donc qui se cache derrière ces
différents
donne beaucoup d'informations sur ces
producteurs mais les voir c'est encore
autre chose et puis qui viennent vous
dire eux-mêmes ce que ça signifie pour
eux l'importance que ça a pour
effectivement le simple cadre de la
consommation on parlait de
d'émancipation de développement
économique on parle
politique
à tout à l'heure merci donc à toutes les
deux d'être venu sur ce plateau je vous
le disais dans une dizaine de minutes ce
rendez-vous n'hésitez pas à vous y
rendre pour en savoir encore plus merci
encore et on vous laisse partir
justement puisque nous sommes toujours
en direct et ce sera donc dans une
dizaine de minutes on va parler pour
l'instant des constructeurs automobiles
l'ambiance qui est toujours morose pour
les constructeurs automobiles c'est dans
ce contexte que s'ouvre le Salon de
Genève pour autant certaines pmegardes
le sourire multiplie les projets
innovants vous en aurez un bon exemple
tout à l'heure avec deux petites
sociétés linoises qui présentent en
Suisse leur création ce sera dans une
demi-heure pour l'instant à la grande
contre la réforme de l'emploi CGT fofsu
et solidaire 4 syndicats est soutenu par
le Front de gauche et par certains
parlementaires socialistes appelés à la
manifestation à la grève ce mardi demain
mercredi sera présenté en Conseil des
ministres le texte qui prévoit notamment
la possibilité pour les employeurs de
réduire le temps de travail et les
rémunérations en cas de difficultés un
texte qui permettra aussi aux salariés
d'obtenir une couverture de santé
complémentaire ce sera obligatoire dès
2016 si le texte est adopté le point sur
la mobilisation dans les Yvelines avec
Anthony Rech et Elodie moine
près de deux mois après la signature de
l'accord interprofessionnel le syndicat
CGT appeller au rassemblement devant le
siège d'Alcatel Lucens avant la
manifestation parisienne selon eux ce
texte augmente la précarité des salariés
ce ne sont pas des améliorations pour
les salariés mais des amaliations pour
les patrons pour licencier plus
facilement et en plus pour limiter les
recours possible du salarié face à un
licenciement qui pourrait être abusif
les manifestants attendent le soutien
des parlementaires yvelinois pour que le
texte ne soit pas voté en l'état faute
de quoi la CGT a laissé entendre
d'éventuelles poursuites devant les
juridictions internationales de son côté
le gouvernement a fait savoir qu'il ne
souhaitait pas la demander ce mercredi
le projet sera présenté au Conseil des
ministres avant d'être débattus à
l'Assemblée nationale d'ici à un mois